after 10 episodes of betrayal subterfuge
plotting rampant incest and numerous
murders the first season of House of the
Dragon ends with big things looming on
the horizon here's what went down
House of the Dragon season 1 depicts
much of King viserys targaryen's tenure
as king of Westeros a tenure that for
the most part is a time of Peace in the
realm we see the questionable
circumstances under which viserys wins
the crown over his more qualified cousin
we see the decisions that lead to his
family slowly falling apart and we see
his ugly death with the old King gone
the blacks and the greens are free to
battle it out for the Iron Throne
however is that the only Legacy that
viserys is to leave behind when he
announces the King's death to the small
Council Otto Hightower refers to him as
viserys the peaceful it's a fitting
title aside from the frequent fighting
with triarchy and the stepstones no
major conflicts seem to occur under
viserys's rule still the king's Legacy
isn't simply one of Peace though the
realm remains United throughout his
Reign his own house begins to crumble
viserys never really earns forgiveness
for his part in the death of his first
wife Queen Emma and the man we see at
the end of season 1 is barely a man at
all more a wisp of one trying
desperately to believe that that all
will be right after his death what will
they say of B then the histories are
written
to King viserys's Credit he never
falters from his conviction that
rhaenyra should be Queen after him
despite the urges from others to name
aegon air however the longtime hand of
the king Otto Hightower has other plans
which begin with him matching his own
daughter with visares and end with him
arranging for Prince aegon to be named
king after viserys's death as Alison
learns at the small council meeting her
father and his allies have been planning
to use serpaneura's Birthright for years
her misunderstanding of viserys's final
words meant to confirm rhaenyra as his
Heir but interpreted as a desire for
aegon to rule is helpful to that end but
hardly necessary Otto would probably
have pushed to install aegon regardless
and given how Allison has acted
throughout the season it's unlikely that
she would have resisted not even the
brutal killing of Lord beesberry by Sir
Kristen Cole or her father's executions
of political dissidents are enough to
sway Allison though it's brought about
by schemes aegon's coronation almost
feels inevitable when it happens as
Princess rhaenis says man what soon to
put them around to the torch
see a woman Ascend the iron throne
Otto claims to be serving the realm but
he just wants his progeny to rule while
Allison feels conflicted her sense of
Duty compels her to support her son's
claim
most opposed of the Dragon episode 9
concerns the Frantic hunt for Prince
aegon after King viserys's death
apparently the Young Prince has no
interest in ruling the Seven Kingdoms
which would seem to suit his younger
brother Eamonn just fine however both
Otto and Allison are determined to seat
aegon on the throne and they eventually
track him down to do just that though
hesitant at first aegon responds quite
positively to the bows and cheers he
receives at his coronation that Newfound
sense of power and importance is sure to
be bad news for the realm however
aegon's list of known crimes include
multiple instances of sexual assault
patronizing child fighting rings in
King's Landing and being an all-around
horrible monster the images of him
lifting his sword as king are sure to
conjure unfavorable comparisons to Game
of Thrones characters like Joffrey
Baratheon with the crown on his head
aegon's Behavior will likely grow even
more harmful Alison expresses
frustration and even rage at her son
throughout season one but at this point
would anything compel her to denounce
him for now Allison seems locked in a
trap that she helped build
King aegon II's coronation is cut short
by surprise appearance from Princess
rhaenice on Dragon back as the
coronation takes place within the dragon
pit it's a simple thing for her to sneak
away climb aboard melees and smash
through the floorboards to escape sure
there are thousands of innocent people
in the way many of whom are likely
killed during the incident but that
seems to be beside the point for the
queen Who Never Was despite the violence
of her appearance rhaenice chooses not
to kill any of the greens instead she
simply flies off to Dragonstone to warn
rhaenyra ultimately allying herself and
the valarian fleet to Rainier's side one
of the most powerful moments in the
house of the Dragon season 1 finale is
Rainier's own coronation where she dons
the same crown that her father wore
while all others present bend the knee
to the queen rhaenis remains standing
looking on with obvious Pride rhaenyra
accomplishes that which rhaenis was
blocked from doing herself so many years
before though she briefly considers
allying herself with the greens the
prince princess refuses to embrace
Allison's belief that women must remain
in the background
no one has a Wilder journey through
House of the Dragon season 1 then Damon
Targaryen he starts off as the king's
bitter younger brother only interested
in ascending to the Iron Throne himself
when his mocking of viserys's dead son
gets him banished he steals a dragon egg
and claims Dragonstone as his own he
eventually winds up fighting in the
stepstones Grooms his niece like a
full-on predator murders his wife
remarries loses his second wife and
ultimately marries rhaenyra for just 10
episodes it's an impressive tale of
treachery the question that still
lingers however is whether or not Damon
can actually be trusted the finale of
season 1 shows him clashing with
rhaenyra on several issues he wants to
go straight to war and use their greater
Dragon numbers to beat the greens into
submission but rhaenyra pushes for a
less violent solution at least at first
when she brings up aegon's prophecy for
why peaceful methods should be embraced
Damon flips out choking her and telling
her that viserys's historical obsessions
were only delusions of grand Dream City
makers Kings
dragon's dead
though he's currently on Rainier's side
this moment of aggression is a grim
reminder of the kind of person Damon
really is he's a power hungry murderer
with an inferiority complex who married
his niece for clout how much longer
should Rainier trust him and what else
might he do for the throne
Damon Targaryen is right about one thing
at the very least the war between Alison
hightower's regime and Rainier's faction
will come down to whose dragons are
stronger at the very end of House of the
Dragon season 1 we get a dark Glimpse at
what that could look like rhaenyra sends
her son luceras alone as an Envoy to
storm Zen to try to secure the
baratheons as allies however when he
arrives Prince aemond is already there
along with his massive Dragon vegar when
luceris leaves Eamonn pursues leading to
a tense Chase through a storm offshore
in the end neither Rider is able to
fully control their Mount leading to
luceris and Eric's perishing in Vegas
gaping maw a tragedy in its own right
lucerus's death also shows just how
dangerous the greens could become sure
rhaenyra and Damon have the numbers when
it comes to Dragons by a lot but that
doesn't guarantee them a victory
Dragonstone has 13 to therefore I also
have a score of eggs incubating in the
dragon Mound
well make that 12. it's hard to imagine
any dragon even caraxis or melees
standing up against vegar that may be
why Damon starts trying to recruit the
remaining riderless dragons beginning
with vermouthor the next largest after
vegar and the former Mount of King
jaharis the First turns out a little
Valyrian singing is all it takes to win
the dragon's heart
before her son lucerus is killed
rhaenyra seems hesitant to engage in an
all-out war against the greens since
House of the Dragon season 1 ends the
moment she learns of the murder we don't
quite know yet how it may change her
plans regardless of her heightened rage
much of rhaenyra's original plan will
likely play out unaltered Lord Corliss
and the valarian fleet can still put
King's Landing under Naval Siege though
that might be tricky with vegar and the
greens other dragons flying about at the
same time rhaenyra still needs more
allies to make a war feasible which is
why Prince jaceris's Mission to the
north is so critical the Aarons and the
Starks are hugely important during the
original Game of Thrones timeline and
they could enter the house of the Dragon
Story in a big way in season two
at its core House of the Dragon season 1
is a story about patriarchy it's a story
about two women who grow up as friends
and are torn apart by the society they
live in one that demands that men rule
while women stand in the background at
the behest of her father Alison
Hightower buys into this world and makes
herself a part of it believing it's the
only way she can have a positive effect
rhaenyra takes the opposite approach
putting everything on the line to assert
her own right to rule as a woman where
Allison prioritizes Duty Above All Else
her friend and rival prioritizes loyalty
where rhaenyra believes in progress
Allison believes in maintaining peace
through the status quo to both of them
princess rhaenys represents a beautiful
what if a woman who could and should
have been put on the iron throne but
whose Birthright was rejected by an
oppressive society when Allison invites
rhenice to join her in the fight against
train era she rejects her you desire not
to be free but make a window in the
world of your prison
for all her flaws rhaenyra dares to
dream of a better world which is why
rhaenys chooses to Ally herself her
dragons and her Fleet to Rainier's cause
aegon the conqueror's dream referred to
by viserys as The Song of Ice and Fire
looms large over everything that happens
in House of the Dragon season 1. it's
the thing that makes viserys believe
that his Reign might yet be legendary
the idea that he alone is preserving
protection for the realm he clearly
believes in aegon's Prophecy and he
makes Rainier believe it too when she's
crowned his Queen the conviction that
only a Targaryen can defend the realm
from darkness is still at the Forefront
of her mind given what happens in Game
of Thrones season 8 this is a curious
thing to focus on the prophecy of the
prince that was promised is thought to
be fulfilled by Daenerys Targaryen and
Jon Snow but neither of them is the one
to actually kill the night King and end
the white walkers rampage that honor
Falls to Arya Stark with this in mind
it's hard to see rhaenyra's belief in
the prophecy as anything other than
misguided yet it's a good enough reason
for her to prepare for war even before
the death of her son though aegon II is
indeed Targaryen he represents a new
line spawned by the high Towers all the
old Valyrian blood is Allied against him
perhaps that means they also have the
power of Fate on their side
rhaenyra asks for Counsel on Dragonstone
in the house of the Dragon season 1
finale miss queen what is my true duty
to the Rome Lord bottomless ensuring
peace and unity or that I sit the Iron
Throne no matter the coast
he says that using dragons in the war
will lead to a land of bone and dash to
counter her uncle husband Damon's
warmongering ever the thoughtful and
strategic leader rhaenyra clearly takes
the safety and well-being of Westeros
seriously so the question remains what
is her dutious Queen is it to ensure the
least possible Bloodshed if so then
bending the knee to egg on the second
might be the best course of action doing
so would prevent war and certainly save
the lives of countless civilians and
foot soldiers however one must also
consider aegon himself a cruel young man
with no sense of decency or honor to
speak of then there's the fact that only
rhaenyra fully understands The Song of
Ice and Fire which compels her to
maintain her claim to the iron throne
for Alison Hightower the duty of a queen
is maintaining a peaceful status quo
while protecting your family at all
costs rhaenyra seems to have a more
holistic view of things but that's
before her son luceras is killed by
Eamonn and vegar perhaps perhaps now her
Duty as a mother and Warrior May
supersede her distaste for violence her
world is full of power-hungry schemers
and corrupt Aristocrats but we've yet to
see exactly what kind of queen she'll be
all in all House of the Dragon season
one leaves a lot of loose ends blowing
in the wind in retrospect the whole Saga
feels like a setup for the real story
the dance of the Dragons itself which
will begin in season 2. HBO officially
ordered season 2 early on in season 1's
run so there's no doubt that it's coming
however according to series co-creator
Ryan Condell filming for season 2 won't
begin until 2023 when it does return we
may see some new faces including
ancestors of some Game of Thrones
favorites there are also sure to be
plenty of dragon on Dragon battles as
the conflict heats up and yeah a lot
more incest as well there are several
engagements currently in the works and
yep most of them are between relatives
you targaryens do you have queer customs
[Music]